Sudan's Army Chief Abdul fatah al-braham
inspecting troops at the headquarters in
cartoon
it's a rare public appearance for the
general his third since fighting between
the Army and paramilitary Rapid support
forces began in mid-april the battle for
control of Sudan shows no sign of ending
on Wednesday Army supporters
demonstrated in cartoon they are
demanding United Nations Envoy Volker
Perth as leave accusing him of
interference
yeah
[Applause]
we demand that volcker the UNM boy be
removed from his position he is
responsible for the conflict because he
has contributed to the division and
separation of the people in this country
both the Army and Rapid support forces
have claimed control of strategic sites
in cartoon this week
[Music]
and both insist they have the upper hand
the two have been holding indirect talks
in Jeddah since the beginning of the
month but they fail to agree on a
permanent resolution a series of
ceasefires have failed
gives a statement that the truce will be
from this hour to that hour the
continued Air Raids and artillery fire
is proof that there is more than one
decision maker in this crisis and it's
one of the reasons that the hostilities
don't end it proves the lack of Will
from the Sudanese Army
and for Sudanese more stalled
negotiations means more uncertainty and
more hardship and suffering people are
leaving cartoon because there's no food
no water no electricity and there is
very high levels of insecurity wfp is
providing hot meals wfp will continue to
support refugees as and when they arrive
for the future is very Bleak for those
people it is Bleak for Sudan and it is
Bleak for the region
more than a month into the conflict the
UN says one million people have been
displaced they can't go home until the
two sides agree to stop fighting Freddie
akar Al Jazeera